why do you have those materials over
there my following a heart of the card I
want to thank my mom because she's a
cool mom visual what are you drawing a
trophy for my dad number one dad because
he's the best guy in the world who can
tell us what you're drawing with a blue
marker hey hot tub well done for my act
we get a monster truck let me use this
to think my mom cuz she took me to the
most attraction I'm gonna doll a cake
my mom is my best friend you like baking
cakes together this is me my god eating
a hamburger if my dad could in a
hamburger every day he would now what is
the hot tub robot it's hot tub it knocks
around it's my mom the kids already done
so I decorated and I have a little
flower vase
there's a hamburger advance how it been
so beautiful Wow that's on the side of
me what about a robot oh my god dances
oh it's got our hamburger on it thank
you so much for this hamburger trophy is
cool in that cold okay
I think everyone in the world is monster
truck thank you mom
I want to thank you for being my best
friend that heart is as much as I love
my mom I hope a crane could hold this
thank you
welcome I love you so much I love you so
much too
is there anybody else you'd like to
think I just wanna thank my dad I also
like to thank my sisters I wanna thank
my teacher because he teaches me how to
learn